[Music]
so
50 years ago when i began exploring the
ocean no one
not jacques perrin not jacques cousteau
or rachel carson
imagined that we could do anything to
harm the ocean by what we put into it or
what we took out of it
it seemed at that time to be a sea of
eden
but now we know and we are now facing
paradise lost
i want to share with you my personal
view of changes in the sea that affect
all of us and to consider why it matters
that in 50 years we've lost
actually we've taken we've eaten more
than 90 percent of the big fish in the
sea
why you should care that nearly half of
the coral reefs have disappeared
why a mysterious depletion of oxygen in
large areas of the pacific should
concern not only the creatures that are
dying
but it really should concern you it does
concern you as well i'm haunted by
the thought of what ray anderson calls
tomorrow's child
asking why we didn't do something on our
watch to save sharks and bluefin tuna
and squids and coral reefs and
the living ocean while there still was
time
well now is that time
i hope for your help
to explore and protect the wild ocean in
ways that will restore the health
and in so doing
secure hope for humankind
health to the ocean means
health for us and i hope jill tarter's
wish to engage earthlings includes
dolphins and whales
and other sea creatures
and this quest to look for intelligent
life elsewhere in the universe and i
hope jill
that someday that we'll find
evidence
that there is intelligent life among
humans on this planet
did i say that i guess i did
for me as a scientist
it all began
in 1953.
when i first tried scuba
it's when i first got to know fish
swimming in something other than lemon
slices and butter
i actually
love
diving at night you see a lot of fish
then you don't see in the daytime
diving day and night was
really easy for me in 1970 when i led a
team of aquanauts living underwater for
weeks at a time
at the same time
that astronauts were putting their
footprints on the moon
in 1979 i had a chance to put my
footprints on the ocean floor while
using this personal submersible called
gym
six miles offshore and 1250 feet down
it's one of my favorite bathing suits
since then i've used about 30 kinds of
submarines and i've even started three
companies and a non-profit foundation
called deep search
to design and build
systems to access the deep sea
i led a five-year national geographic
expedition the sustainable seas
expeditions using these little subs
they're so simple to drive that even a
scientist can do it
and i'm living proof
astronauts and aquanauts alike really
appreciate the importance of air food
water temperature
all the things you need to stay alive in
space
or under the sea
i heard astronaut joe allen explain how
he had to learn everything he could
about his life support system
and then do everything he could to take
care of his life support system
and then he pointed to this and he said
life support system
we need to learn everything we can about
it and do everything we can to take care
of it
the poet auden said
thousands have lived without love
none without water
97 of earth's water is ocean no blue no
green
if you think the ocean isn't important
imagine earth without it
mars comes to mind no ocean no life
support system
i gave a talk not so long ago at the
world bank
and i showed this amazing image of earth
and i said there it is
the world bank
that's where all the assets are
[Applause]
we've been drawing them down much faster
than the natural systems can replenish
them
timworth says the economy is a wholly
owned subsidiary of the environment with
every drop of water you drink every
breath you take
you're connected to the sea no matter
where on earth you live
most of the oxygen in the atmosphere is
generated by the sea over time most of
the planet's organic carbon has been
absorbed and stored there mostly by
microbes
the ocean drives climate and weather
stabilizes temperature shapes earth's
chemistry
water from the sea forms clouds that
return to the land and the sea is rain
sleet and snow
and provides home for about 97
of life in the world maybe in the
universe no water no life
no blue no green
yet we have this idea we humans
that the earth all of it the oceans the
skies are so vast so resilient it
doesn't matter what we do to it
that may have been true ten thousand
years ago and maybe even a thousand
years ago
but in the last hundred especially the
last fifty we've drawn down the assets
the air the water the wildlife
that make our lives possible
new technologies are helping us
to understand
the nature
of nature
the nature of what's happening
showing us
our impact on the earth
i mean first you have to know that
you've got a problem
and fortunately in our time we've
learned more about the problems than in
all preceding history
and with knowing comes caring with
caring there's hope that we can find an
enduring place for ourselves within the
natural systems that support us but
first
we have to know
three years ago i met john hanke who's
the head of google earth and i told him
how much i love being able to hold the
world in my hands and go exploring
vicariously
but i asked him when are you going to
finish it he did a great job with the
land the dirt
what about the water
since then i've had the great pleasure
of working with the googlers
with doer marine with a national
geographic with dozens of the best
institutions and scientists around the
world ones that we could enlist to put
the ocean in google earth and as of just
this week last monday google earth
is now whole
consider this starting right here at the
convention center we can find the nearby
aquarium we can look at where we're
sitting and then cruise up the coast to
the big
aquarium the ocean
and california is for national marine
sanctuaries and a new network of state
marine reserves that are beginning to
protect
and restore some of the assets
we can fleet over to hawaii and see the
real hawaiian islands
not just the little bit that pokes
through the surface
but also what's below
to see
wait a minute we can go
right there
under the ocean and see
what the whales see
we can go explore
the other side of the hawaiian islands
we can go actually and swim around on
google earth
and visit with humpback whales
these are gentle giants that i've had
the pleasure of meeting face to face
many times underwater
there's nothing quite like being
personally inspected by a whale
we can pick up and fly to the deepest
place seven miles down the mariana
trench where only two people have ever
been imagine that
it's only seven miles but only two
people have been there 49 years ago
one way trips are easy we need new deep
diving submarines how about some x
prizes for ocean exploration
we need to see deep trenches the
undersea mountains
and understand life in the deep sea
we can now go to the arctic
just ten years ago i stood on the ice at
the north pole
an ice-free arctic ocean
may happen in this century
that's bad news for the polar bears
it's bad news for us too
excess carbon dioxide is not only
driving global warming it's also
changing ocean chemistry making the sea
more acidic
that's bad news for coral reefs and
oxygen producing plankton also bad news
for us
we're putting
hundreds of millions of tons of plastic
and other trash into the sea millions of
tons of discarded fishing nets
gear that continues to kill
we're clogging the ocean
poisoning the planet's circulatory
system and we're taking out hundreds of
millions of tons of wildlife
all carbon based units
barbarically we're killing sharks for
shark fin soup
undermining food chains that shape
planetary chemistry and drive the carbon
cycle the nitrogen cycle the oxygen
cycle the water cycle
our life support system
incredibly we're still killing bluefin
tuna truly endangered and much more
valuable alive than dead
all of these parts
are part of our life support system
we kill using long lines with baited
hooks every few feet that may stretch
for 50 miles or more
industrial trawlers and draggers are
scraping the sea floor like bulldozers
taking everything in their path
using google earth you can witness
trawlers in china the north sea the gulf
of mexico
shaking the foundation of our life
support system leaving plumes of death
in their path
the next time you dine on sushi or
sashimi or swordfish steak or shrimp
cocktail or whatever wildlife you happen
to enjoy from the ocean
think
of the real cost
for every pound that goes to market
more than 10 pounds
even a hundred pounds
may be thrown away
as bycatch
this is the consequence
of not knowing that there are limits to
what we can take out of the sea
this chart shows a decline in ocean
wildlife from 1900
to 2000 the highest concentrations are
in red
in my lifetime imagine 90
of the big fish have been killed most of
the turtles sharks tunas and whales are
way down in numbers but there is good
news
ten percent of the big fish still remain
there's still some blue whales there's
still some krill in antarctica there are
a few oysters in chesapeake bay
half the coral reefs are still in pretty
good shape a jeweled belt around the
middle of the planet
there's still time
but not a lot to turn things around
but business as usual means that in 50
years there may be no coral reefs and no
commercial fishing because
the fish will simply be gone
imagine
the ocean without fish
imagine what that means to our life
support system
natural systems on the land are in big
trouble too but the problems are more
obvious
and some actions are being taken to
protect trees watersheds and wildlife
and in 1872 with yellowstone national
park the united states began
establishing a system of parks
that some say was the best idea america
ever had
about 12 percent of the land around the
world is now protected
safeguarding biodiversity providing a
carbon sink generating oxygen protecting
watersheds
and in 1972 this nation began to
establish a counterpart in the sea
national marine sanctuaries it's another
great idea
the good news is
that they're now more than 4 000 places
in the sea around the world that have
some kind of protection and you can find
them on google earth
the bad news is
that you have to look hard to find them
in the last three years for example the
u.s protected 340 000 square miles of
ocean as national monuments
but it only increased from 0.6 of 1
to 0.8 of one percent of the ocean
protected globally
protected areas do rebound but it takes
a long time to restore
fifty-year-old rockfish or monkfish
sharks or sea bass or two
hundred-year-old orange ruffy
we don't consume 200 year old cows or
chickens
protected areas provide hope
that the creatures
of ed wilson's dream of an encyclopedia
of life or the census of marine life
will live
not just as a list
a photograph
or a paragraph
with scientists around the world i've
been looking at the 99 of the ocean that
is open to fishing and mining and
drilling and dumping and whatever
to search out hope spots and try to find
ways to give them and us a secure future
such as the arctic we have one chance
right now to get it right
or the antarctic where the continent is
protected but the surrounding ocean is
being stripped of its krill whales and
fish
sargasso sees three million square miles
of floating forest is being gathered up
to feed cows
97 of the land in the galapagos islands
is protected but the adjacent sea is
being ravaged by fishing
it's true too
in argentina on the patagonian shelf now
in serious trouble
the high seas where whales tunas and
dolphins travel
the largest least protected ecosystem on
earth
filled with luminous creatures
living in dark waters that average two
miles deep
they flash and sparkle and glow with
their own
living light
they're still places in the sea as
pristine as i knew as a child
the next 10 years may be the most
important in the next 10 000 years the
best chance our species will have to
protect what remains of the natural
systems that give us life
to cope with climate change we need new
ways to generate power
we need new ways better ways to cope
with poverty wars and disease we need
many things to keep and maintain the
world as a better place
but nothing else will matter
if we fail to protect the ocean our fate
in the ocean
are one
we need to do for the ocean what al gore
did for the skies above
a global plan of action
with a world conservation union the iucn
is underway to protect biodiversity to
mitigate and recover from the impacts of
climate change
on the high seas and in coastal areas
wherever
we can identify critical places
new technologies are needed to map
photograph and explore the 95 of the
ocean that we have yet to see
the goal is to protect biodiversity
provide stability and resilience
we need deep diving subs new
technologies to explore the ocean
we need maybe an expedition a ted at sea
that could help figure out next steps
and so i suppose you want to know what
my wish is
i wish
you would use all means at your disposal
films expeditions the web new submarines
a campaign to ignite public support for
a global network of marine protected
areas
hope spots
large enough to save and restore the
ocean the blue heart of the planet
how much
some say 10 percent
some say 30 percent you decide how much
of your heart do you want to protect
whatever it is
a fraction of one percent is not enough
my wish is a big wish but if we can make
it happen
it can truly change the world
and help ensure the survival
of what actually
is as it turns out my favorite species
that would be us
for the children of today for tomorrow's
child as never again
now
is the time
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you